casque sur les oreilles les voilà équipé
ses visiteurs vont participer à une api
manif une déambulation dans le quartier
17 mar pensé par le chorégraphe david
rolland nous lui avons demandé une api
manif spécialement écrite qui c'est qui
s'appelle la croisée des arts entre
culture et patrimoine
donc c'est le travail qu'il a fait en
partenariat avec le musée de la ville
qui lui a donné énormément de
renseignement il a écrit ses partitions
c'est un quartier des années 70 qui a
été inaugurée en 76
il ya toute une architecture on a
peut-être oublié dans ce quartier au
temps des immeubles que des objets d'art
qui sont situés autour pendant que vous
vous éparpillez on écoute ma dame des
landes architecte avec son mari du
quartier 17 mar et donc on est partis
tous les deux venise et on a mesuré
toutes les places qui nous prouvait pld
qui nous une quarantaine de minutes de
voyage dans le quartier lors de cette
journée du patrimoine des haltes
historiques se sont mêlés aux instants
culturel comme telle sculpture de klaus
schulze la main divine on s'appelle ceux
d'un homme puis d'or et qui rêve et il
est absolument quand même il n'y a rien
du tout autour de lui et très surprenant
donc la particularité c'est vrai que
chacun donc été isolé d'une certaine
façon et on était tous ensemble en même
temps dans le principe on a découvert
donc le quartier de cette marque que je
connaissais pas du tout ce qui était
intéressant aussi c'est de découvrir des
éléments d'architecturé
c'est à dire de danser dans l'espace
avec les autres et dans cet espace
urbain
une cinquantaine de participants ont
dansé à travers les allées l'an
courtoise pour terminer sur une
chorégraphie énergie
aujourd'hui mais je veux c'est gentiment
je veux ce bâtiment